you  humanity's best weapon  master chief huh  the master chief was enhanced and  trained for one purpose  to win this war  he and the other spartans  are our only effective weapons against  the covenant  [Music]  he is lethal  upgradable  and most importantly  controllable  covenant forces appear to be excavating  some kind of object  when i touch the object i felt something  it felt  different  what they did to us  makes you known  and you just decided to help me why  wouldn't spartan do that  what does one do with a superhuman  you're not sure you can trust  hello master chief  i'm cortana  master chief recovered something sacred  ring halo  [Applause]  humans  to the covenant  cortana i'm gonna need you now  find the halo win the war  you